am I just the only one who is not mad
about the way that the traffic works in
this game and I am not kidding I've seen
many people complain that there are
actually bugs in the traffic right now
because cars keep piling up and you keep
having problems with traffic well I
think that's actually good thing isn't
it well about the game I mean it's not a
good thing if your traffic is doing that
stuff but I am really happy actually
about the traffic engine and it is very
challenging to actually get your traffic
to not screw up and be congested all
over the place and it is definitely very
rewarding if you actually do get your
traffic to work so I am actually very
happy about the way that engine works
some things that I am not too happy
about though or nothing at the moment
I'm not really mad about anything in the
game it's really a joy to play so far
but yeah in this episode I decided that
keeping in mind that traffic in this
game is a complete bummer and will
always screw you over in many ways this
is going to be the one episode in which
I am going to completely redo my
industrial areas and I was kind of
experimenting with one leg wet one-way
roads thank you very much because as you
might know traffic lights in this game
are and you want to avoid them if you
can and one way to avoid those things is
one lane roads they are the future and
that means no traffic lights no stopping
cars even if the intersection is not
that busy and at this point and we're
still trying to kind of fix that ring
over there but I was like nope
and that doesn't work either let's just
either let's just remove the entire area
because this is not working for me so I
did just that and now the entire
industrial everything is gone and it
will be completely redone in a minute
and this little thingy over here was
also not too practical and I was like
okay if I want to have some on and off
ramps for the highway if they're very
commonly used you're gonna have to
connect them in some other way than a
way that gets you traffic lights because
at this point my my brain was just
focused on don't get the traffic lights
and I didn't want to get run about
either not per se actually be but I
still kind of use them but the entire
industry
your area kind of turned into a
roundabout and that's something that
you'll see in a minute and this is
definitely not a tutorial because you
know this this is something that I think
really works and you might actually use
this video as a tutorial but it is not
but I'll tell you that I was actually
pretty happy with these industrial areas
the way that they work is you get this
on-ramp and you get this off-ramp which
connects to two places on the highway so
until we get four ramps and the ramp in
the ramps in one direction pair up and
the two other two ramps also pair up and
they form one road which connects to
that little roundabout over there which
you can see and in the same direction as
the roundabout rapid so whoa whoa whoa
okay in the same direction as the
roundabout you're going to want to place
all of your roads in your industrial
area and at the end of the roundabout
you're probably going to want to have
some kind of connection to the other
roads because if you if you're using
one-way roads that should also be the
possibility of using one-way roads to
transport goods within the industrial
area otherwise your trucks are going to
get over highways and they're gonna get
off on the nearest on-ramp and then
they're gonna drive over the highway and
get back on the on-ramp to the highway
and they're gonna spend lots of time and
congest your entire highway doing that
so that is something you should avoid
enter traffic within the industrial area
itself should also be possible but yeah
as you can see you have this little
roundabout and then you have the one
brave roads around it which also go in I
kind of run about especially in that
left section and the way that this works
is all the trucks that want to get into
the industrial area are going to have to
collect and come together in one place
then they're all going to have to split
up and go to all the various companies
that they're gonna have to go to and
deliver goods to and then they're gonna
turn back around and they're all gonna
join again and they're gonna go on the
highways and go in their various
directions and then leave your
industrial areas and you're not gonna
have too much traffic congestion at
least that was the idea and then I did
get a tiny bit of traffic congestion but
not as bad as I used to have it I used
to have red zones everywhere and now
there are a couple of orange spots and a
couple
of slightly red spots but nothing else
it's not really anything too bad so I'm
happy about that industrial zone right
now even though they are going to be
there later in a future
yeah I'm really sad about that but these
these industrial zones are going to have
to go the education levels are going to
rise and with the education levels the
issue with industrial zones is that only
uneducated people can work and in them
and if you're gonna have loads of
industrial zones even if you already
have high schools and university and of
course elementary schools everywhere
then you're gonna have highly educated
people working on lowly educated jobs
and perhaps you're even going to have a
shortage of jobs and either the
industrial areas are going to have
problems actually sustaining their
companies or you're gonna have
overworked workers and that is
definitely not what you'd want to have
so avoid that if you can remove those
industrial zones if you can and don't be
like a stupid person who doesn't because
I can speak from experience that that is
going to cost you so yeah at this point
I was like I say that way too often damn
I need to say I need to stop saying that
ok so there you're going to see that I
am actually going to do some work on the
transportation stuff because bus lines
is something that I did not have too
many of yet and stupidly surprisingly my
goal for setting up bus lines was not to
get a splendid public transport system
but rather to get those thousand
passengers a what was it a year or a
week I think it was a week and actually
get the transport hour because that is a
beautiful sexy skyscraper
and definitely something I want to add
to my collection that is my downtown and
you know if I could actually nitpick
about this game even though you know it
isn't it picking after all it's that
there is a lack of actually really tall
skyscrapers I think the tallest
skyscrapers in this game are about 30
stories high and I'm not really a huge
fan of that when as soon as you get a
really big city filled with skyscrapers
they're all going to be the same size
papers and they're all gonna have the
same height now that's not to say that
we are not going to get more skyscrapers
because this
is still sort of in beta and it is very
mobile and anyone can add assets even
from Sketchup by the way I am planning
on actually importing buildings myself
actually going into Sketchup and getting
3ds max and doing whatever I have to do
because I really want to import
buildings but yeah it's probably going
to happen but right now many cities are
just filled with the same buildings all
over the place and it's not something
that I am really enjoying too much right
now but as soon as I can of course I'm
going to just open the 3d warehouse in
Sketchup and import all the models that
I can even if they have terrible poet
accounts I don't I don't care you know
this is an nvidia 970 GTX and it better
sure handle it and at this point I was
like oh god I said it again here as you
can see I replaced all of these zones
with density lots of density in both
commercial and residential aspects
because I was like I have these river
banks and I'm not building anything on
them and I might as well built stuff on
them because I need more population and
I still have that ridiculous demand for
industry so I'm also placing all of that
industry and especially the forest
industry which I am pretty sure is less
dense in a sense that it doesn't have as
many workers per square meter I suppose
than the normal industry of the farming
industry which is already less efficient
than the normal industry it seems so I
don't know if that was really the best
idea if I really wanted to have more
workers working in the industrial zones
but I decided to do it anyway because
those things look good yeah probably
more often than I should I like to use
good-looking things more than practical
things now something that I do like
though which is both good-looking and
practical I suppose is that I saw that
this roundabout had some huge problems
trying to sort out what kind of traffic
was trying to go through it so I let
that small a tall ramp over there which
means that all the traffic from the left
can just use the ramp and not have to go
through any more traffic intersections
to go back on the highway and that also
meant that the roundabout wasn't quite
as crowded anymore
and in the end I didn't really have any
problems with the traffic over here in
this area so I'm really happy about that
too and at this point I was like oh my
god I said it again I had all of these
huge plants near the riverbank and it
doesn't really look like the best thing
ever for one because it's kind of
communist architecture and that's not
really the best thing in my opinion but
it also looks very weird if you have one
big wall of flats next to your river and
behind that are just small crappy houses
so yeah I really had to remove those
buildings because they were kind of out
of place over there and that's the issue
with that but here it is going to be a
moment of glory because as it turns out
I get a thousand passengers a week on
the public transport and that is exactly
what I needed and I got the transport
hour and life was amazing I can tell you
so I had to find a spot for this
transport hour in the middle of the
downtown though and yeah there were many
buildings over there and I wouldn't
really rode where I could actually place
it I was trying to move around any
everywhere but I also didn't want to
remove really nice-looking buildings and
in the end I just decided to go for
destroy everything and get a new road
pattern which probably wasn't the best
idea in the end because it destroyed
half of the downtown but I could Leslie
transmit our so that that worked and I
had this weird kind of grid over here
which I didn't once but you can use
pedestrian paths and connect them to a
road it's got rid of all those squares
next to a road and even though that
seems like a counterproductive at first
it does mean that if you have another
rope which is very close to that road
and they're kind of blocking their grids
and making sure that no grid is actually
allowed to have any high-rise then you
can just use a path on one of them and
get more grid space and actually be able
to place high-rise so that's what I did
in that case and as you can see the
downtown is slowly developing into a
nicer and more beautiful downtown but
yeah that's it for this episode so thank
you for watching and I'll see you on the
next episode